you
to many people myself included getting
into bed at the end of the day is the
most wonderful experience imaginable you
get to shrug off the stress of the day
and close your eyes and before you know
it you're off to Dreamland and then
you're falling out of an airplane being
hunted by an axe murderer or in my case
being chased by an enormous B whether
you remember it or not everybody dreams
sometimes dreams are very pleasant and
sometimes they're downright terrifying
dreams are an integral part of most
people's nightly life but where do they
come from
to better understand dreams we first
have to look at why we sleep in the
first place when you sleep you fall into
an anabolic state in which your body
builds up the immune nervous skeletal
and muscular systems and as any student
will tell you bad things start to happen
when you don't get enough sleep this
condition known as sleep deprivation can
lead to problems such as fatigue
sleepiness clumsiness and weight loss or
weight gain depending on the individual
after a certain amount of time without
sleep
you simply can't function according to
sleep experts getting between roughly 7
and 9 hours of sleep per night is ideal
that gives your body enough time to
essentially run a systems check and
release hormones that help maintain your
immune system and retain memory but what
happens during those eight hours of
unconsciousness
what's the brain doing that gives us
those vivid often bizarre dreams once
your head hits the pillow and you drift
off your unconscious body takes over and
sleep recedes in cycles and REM to REM
about four or five times per night there
are three different stages of n room and
REM one or light sleep and REM two and n
rm3 or slow wave sleep these periods
usually proceed in the order N one and
two and three and two REM sleep it is
during these periods of REM sleep that
are most memorable and vivid dreams
occur REM stands for rapid eye movement
and during this stage your eyes are
doing just that they dart around under
your eyelids like little pin balls other
characteristics of REM sleep include
paralysis in which signals are sent to
the spinal cord commanding its shutoff
movement stimulation in the regions of
the brain that are used for learning and
signals being sent to the brain cerebral
cortex the region responsible for
learning thinking and organizing
information in the last third or so of
the night the boogeyman shows up this is
when the effects of REM sleep are the
strongest nightmares are probably the
third worst thing in a child's life
after Brussels sprouts and homework I
say children because youth are afflicted
with
nightmares at a higher rate than adults
at 10 to 50 percent versus 2 to 8% the
portion of the brain known as the
amygdala is likely responsible for those
unpleasant visions as neuroimaging
studies have shown it to be highly
active during REM sleep as well as
during the day when a person is dealing
with negative emotions when you're awake
you can think logically and dismiss
these negative thoughts but when your
body is unconscious along with parts of
your brain you become trapped in your
own mind and this leads to nightmares
other factors that influence nightmare
frequency and severity are past trauma
and security and important life changes
these negative emotions often manifest
themselves as symbols or metaphors in
our dreams the end of a relationship
could show up as an ax-murderer
symbolizing a chapter of life brought
forcefully to a close though they may
seem like a completely different beast
nightmares are still classified as
dreams during REM sleep is when you'll
experience talking animals flying and
all your other usual dreams but why does
it happen well frankly scientists have
yet to fully understand why we dream of
the signals sent to the cerebral cortex
during REM sleep some of them seem to be
random scientists believes that these
random signals are the bedrock of
dreaming as the brain may be trying to
interpret or find meaning in these
signals resulting in dreaming dreams
also tend to mimic recent experiences
for example if the previous day I were
learning to drive the brain is likely to
recall those electrical impulses and
replay them then since you don't
actually see anything when you're asleep
in order to make sense of the impulses
the brain conjures up memories from
random days and events which explains
the strangeness we experience in many
dreams one likely cause for dreams is
that during REM sleep your brain is
acting as though it's wide awake even
though your body is unconscious the full
responsibility of generating images and
feelings therefore falls to the brain
and without the aid of a conscious body
the conclusions that draws can be very
vague or bizarre as of right now
researchers can't directly access dreams
this means that studying them is more
difficult than most other subjects and
often requires less precise methods such
as provoking subjects to wake up
suddenly during their sleep to record
their experiences however there is a
group working on a machine learning
based analysis of dreams here's how it
works
participants are hooked up to an
electroencephalograph eMachines
or EEG and then fall asleep inside an
fMRI machine the subjects are then woken
up as soon as an electroencephalogram
signature is detected on average roughly
three hundred forty two seconds after
falling
sleeeeep the subject is then asked to
describe their visual experiences before
awakening this procedure is repeated to
attain at least 200 awakenings with a
visual report for each participant from
the collected reports the word subjects
used to describe their dreams are mapped
into wordnet a lexical database in which
similar words are grouped into what are
called since s in a hierarchical
structure the researchers then gather
images corresponding with those words to
train their learning algorithm this
algorithm is so advanced it's able to
utilize the fMRI data to essentially
recreate dreams in video form using the
input training images one interesting
thing to note about this particular
study is that it questions the idea that
REM sleep is when most dreaming occurs
researchers found that dreams can and do
occur in sleep stages 1 & 2 which
allowed them to save time by waking up
their subjects much earlier into their
sleep cycles though this learning
algorithm is far from perfect and does
take a large individualized time
commitment it does bode well for the
feature of dream science maybe someday
we'll even get to record our dreams and
play them back whenever we want so I
don't know how often I want to watch
myself being chased by a giant B as
always this video was intended to spark
your curiosity in the subject if you're
interested in learning more about dreams
check out the links in the description
if you enjoyed this video please
subscribe to my channel to help me keep
putting out interesting content feel
free to leave a like or a dislike as you
please and comment down below to share
some of your crazy dreams you can watch
my previous video by clicking here or
watch them all by clicking here thanks
for watching and I'll see you in the
next video
[Music]